all right Samantha yes Samantha where
are you from originally where'd you grow
up I'm from Tennessee Tennessee what
part
um it's an old town called Greenback
where's that near
it's near like Maryville Knoxville
um Chattanooga all that yeah so
tell me about your family growing up
um I grew up in Little City uh with my
grandparents but I actually started out
in North Carolina until I was 10 and
then I moved to Tennessee to live with
my grandparents my dad's fan my dad's
parents
and stayed there till I left home
was your childhood like how would you
describe it
uh who
it was it was great when
I was around people
with the rough spots
yeah a few
what kind of stuff
did you go through
um
having to pay certain certain people's
debts for them I'm just gonna say that
I don't want to say it all but how do
you pay somebody's debt for me
I mean how anybody else would
being a girl oh I see
no more yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of girl were you in high
school I was outgoing I was always small
and I played basketball on one of the
you know best players
I was Captain
um
what do you want to do with your life
when you grew up when I grew up oh
goodness I wanted to
well I started out wanting to do hair
but that didn't work out but really I
wanted to be uh
like
how to explain it I wanted to save the
world
like the outcast like me
I don't know because I'm different I'm
not like everybody else
yeah and drugs came into your life at
some point
yeah they came into my life whenever my
dad started going to jail
because my dad was my best friend
but also we were
fighting a lot
like we loved each other but it just you
know we never would work that happens
you know we'd be around each other for
24 hours and then we start potting over
something silly but
what kind of drugs are you playing
around with oh right now
or just then well then and then I was on
a methamphetamines I was shooting
I was using a needle I'm not on the
needle no more but
what are you using currently I just used
the Betty but it just helps with my
anxiety and stuff but I've almost quit
it too I'm almost drug-free
thank goodness
are you homeless now
uh right now yeah how long you been down
here I've been here two years
that's good wrote oh yeah really I've
not seen you before yeah you've talked
to me once before but my hair wasn't
this color oh really yeah or maybe I
don't remember you for that reason
it's because of this place is why
I can be thankful I'm able to quit
it's not a good place for it's not a
good place for people that want to stay
in it no
the ones that want to get out yeah it's
great but for a single female it's gonna
be really rough it can't be
it's been the roughest thing you've seen
um
foreign
this place necessarily it's everywhere
but
um here was a little rough at first
because I was acting silly what kind of
things should be done for money
I've had upset with people I know
yeah I have once twice maybe
but not not as a job no I think
everybody pretty much does that male and
female is not always that's why I don't
really agree with the prostitution law
because it's the person's decision
whether or not they want to do it you
know it could be legalized huh should it
be legalized no no no
I don't agree with it being legalized no
but I just don't think that there should
be it should be a crime
I mean they're just they're just paying
somebody to you know
it's almost like therapy yeah
really truthfully yeah
do you have children yes I have two
where are they they stay in Tennessee uh
I was going through a rough patch where
I was going couch to couch and I didn't
want to pull my kids around like that so
I'm gonna sign my rights away
temporarily but then I never went back
because I kept staying on drugs so how
old do you know I'm 30.
how old are you kids uh
when I was born in 2014 the other was
2017.
she's young
do you have any friends down here
um
yes and no
they're friends I have the people that
care about my well-being I can say that
I'm not gonna say they're my friends
because I don't hang out with them I
don't even really speak to them
do you have any regrets in your life oh
plenty
I just wanted to be just like Dad
when I started you know acting silly
um
bad idea
I haven't been able to escape it
yeah
what does this lifestyle do to you
emotionally emotionally it's made me an
emotional wreck
because that's all you think about is
your next fix
yeah fentanyl is a lot harder than
Crystal Method not really it's not that
bad no no
not as bad as I thought it was the
crystal methods where my weakness was
awful
really really bad maybe it's harder to
quit oh yeah because it gives you that
boosting energy that
just different things I mean you could
stay up for days not a mess yes
but I'm saying fentanyl is going to be
harder to quit no
yeah
no I can just not go get it and be just
fine
it's just you get a little sweaty you
know a little groggy but you can push
through it if you just keep going and
sweat it out and you're fine okay you
make it sound easy yeah I mean people
are just lazy
be honest with you really I was lazy
like that until I figured it out
where would you like to be in five years
where would I like to be I'd like to
have like my own place and have material
you know all the materialistic things
that everybody else has the car a few
kids
uh
uh not really
really
but yeah I guess why not your kids I
gave up
telling myself I couldn't do it
I don't want to do that again are they
better off where they're at
huh are they better off where they're at
now
has it been rough for me are the kids
better off with oh yeah of course yeah
so I thought but not really
what's your biggest fear now
um
I guess dying alone
to be honest
[Music]
yeah a couple times for being depressed
just not caring and keep smoking and
smoking smoking and smoking until it
knocks me out
staying in people's tents
um no I normally go inside when I go to
sleep
not a friend's place
you have somebody you can stay with oh
yeah
I have a couple places but
I don't like to be a burden or anybody I
don't want them to think that they have
to help me
I just I'm not big on shelters me in
shelters ugh I can't handle the
I'm a kind of like a germaphobe what do
you think of skid row then which is the
filthiest place when I first got here it
was awful and it was so bad
I couldn't believe it it's filthy yeah
it was a dark dark place it still is
yeah I really was but now it's not not
as dark like at night it's not as dark
or nothing like everybody actually is
like getting along
there's not as much
anger and evil anymore
maybe you're getting used to it
no it's they're listening finally
it doesn't
the evil that they have in their heart
is never going to go away but they can
get past it if they would just try
and Love's got a lot to do with that
people are finding different people
that's come over here
and they're trying to finding their true
love you know
you've been in love before
yeah
I'm a hard rock but it's okay
you know Samantha what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
your most important
oh wow
being the responsible one
I'm always the drag designated driver
I'm always the one that oh I can only do
just a little bit
because I gotta be able to function
because so y'all don't act crazy out
here
I've always been like the little mama
because I was always so scared of losing
somebody right there in front of me
and yet you're still here yeah I'm very
lucky to be too
it's been a few occasions where I should
come in yeah all right Samantha thank
you so much for sharing your story thank
you I wish you lots of luck thanks thank
you